este es el mismo problema que tuvimos en
el último vídeo pero en vez de
establecer si los datos proveen
suficiente evidencia para concluir que
los motores cumplen con los nuevos
requerimientos de emisiones y toda la
prueba de hipótesis se me ocurrió usar
los mismos datos que teníamos en el
último vídeo para obtener un intervalo
de confianza del 95% así que podemos
ignorar esta pregunta podemos ignorar
todo esto simplemente estoy usando los
mismos datos para obtener un intervalo
de confianza el 95% para la media actual
de emisiones de este nuevo diseño de
motor así que queremos encontrar un
intervalo de confianza del 95% un
intervalo de confianza del 95% y como
puedes imaginar dado que sólo tenemos 10
datos estaremos usando una distribución
t y aquí abajo tengo una tabla t y
queremos un intervalo de confianza el
95% el cual podemos pensar como un rango
de valores t que va contra el 95% o más
bien un rango en el cual el 95% de los
valores te van ubicarse vamos a pensarlo
de esta manera voy a dibujar aquí
una distribución de la distribución te
es muy parecida a la distribución normal
solo que la distribución te tiene colas
más gruesas esta cola y esta cola van a
ser más gruesas que en la distribución
normal entonces lo que queremos
encontrar es un intervalo si esta es una
distribución
normalizada aquí tenemos la media igual
a 0 y lo que queremos encontrar es un
intervalo que comprende un valor
negativo y un valor positivo entre los
cuales se va a encontrar el 95% de la
probabilidad así esto de aquí tiene que
ser 95 % y para establecer cuáles son
los valores críticos de t en esta cola y
en esta otra cola vamos a una tabla de
valores de y vamos a usar la versión de
dos colas pues tenemos simetría
alrededor del centro entonces viendo en
la tabla de dos colas queremos un
intervalo confianza del 95% aquí lo
tenemos 95% tenemos 10 datos lo cual
significa que tenemos 9 grados de
libertad así es que 9 grados de libertad
para 10
simplemente restamos 10 menos 1 si
buscamos entonces en la tabla para una
distribución t con 9 grados de libertad
tenemos una probabilidad del 95% que
esté contenido en un valor crítico de
2.26 2 así que los valores te van a
estar comprendidos entre por el lado
positivo 2.26 2 y por el lado negativo
va a ser menos 2.26 2 lo que esto nos
muestra entonces es que los valores
comprendidos hasta 2.232 con respecto al
centro de la distribución te van a
comprender un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad así que aquí tenemos
nuestra distribución te déjame
estipularlo claramente distribución
distribución t así que si tú eliges
aleatoriamente un valor t a partir de
esta distribución tiene una probabilidad
del 95% de encontrarse dentro de este
rango con respecto a la media tengo que
ponerlo de esta manera si elijo un valor
de t si elijo un estadístico t al azar
vamos a reescribir lo mejor así hay un
95 por ciento de probabilidad que un
valor aleatorio
dt un valor de la torre el estadístico t
sea menor que 2.262 y mayor que mayor
que menos 2 - 2.232 hay un 95 por ciento
de probabilidad ahora cuando tomamos
nuestra muestra aquí también podemos
obtener un valor de t a partir de
nuestros datos muestran calculamos el
valor de la media y eso lo puedes
obtener del vídeo anterior o simplemente
sumas estos valores y divides entre 10 y
obtenemos el valor
17.17 y una desviación estándar de 2.98
el estadístico t que podemos obtener
entonces de esta información
déjame escribirlo por acá abajo y
podemos ver este estadístico t como una
muestra aleatoria tomada de esta
distribución t una distribución t con 9
grados de libertad y el estadístico t
que podemos construir va a estar dado
por la media de la muestra que es igual
a 17.17 menos la media real de nuestra
población o de hecho podríamos decir que
es la media real de la distribución
muestral de medias que coincide con la
media real de la población esa es la
media entonces de nuestra población
dividida entre la desviación estándar la
desviación estándar que es de 2.98
dividido entre la raíz del tamaño de
muestra que nuestro caso es 10 esto ya
lo hemos hecho varias veces y esto de
aquí es el estadístico t así que al
tomar esta muestra podemos decir que
tomamos aleatoriamente un estadístico de
esta distribución t con 9 grados de
libertad así que tenemos un 90
por ciento probabilidad que esto de aquí
que esto que tenemos aquí va a estar
entre menor a 2.232 y mayor a menos
2.262 así el 95 por ciento de
probabilidad también aplica aquí tenemos
que hacer algo de aritmética calcular
estas cosas si es que déjame sacar mi
calculadora simplemente saco mi
calculadora voy a calcular entonces este
denominador que tenemos aquí es igual a
2.98 dividido entre raíz de 10 esto nos
da punto 942 3.942 3 lo que voy a hacer
entonces es multiplicar ambos lados de
esta ecuación por esta expresión que
tenemos aquí así que si hago eso si
multiplicó este lado de la ecuación de
hecho estas son dos ecuaciones o más
bien son en realidad dos desigualdades
esta cantidad es mayor que esta cantidad
y ésta
mayor que esta cantidad pero podemos
operar a ambos lados de la desigualdad
al mismo tiempo así que lo que queremos
hacer es multiplicar toda la desigualdad
por este valor que tenemos aquí entonces
vamos a poner el resultado de este valor
por acá a dejar ponerlo por acá sería
2.98 entre raíz de 10 esto es igual a
punto 9 42 así que si multiplicamos toda
la desigualdad por punto 942 que
obtenemos del lado izquierdo tenemos
menos 2.262 x x punto 942 y dado que
estamos multiplicando toda la
desigualdad por un número positivo no se
alteran los signos de la desigualdad y
esto es menor que estamos multiplicando
toda esta expresión por el valor del
denominador así es que se cancelan nos
queda entonces
17.17 menos la media poblacional
y esto es menor que 2.262 x de nueva
cuenta punto 942 deje mover un poco
hacia la derecha
punto 942 y para que quede claro estamos
multiplicando los tres lados de esta
desigualdad por este valor de aquí esta
parte central se cancela así es que si
estamos multiplicando por punto 942 esto
acá por punto 942 y este acá también por
punto 942 este y este son el mismo
número es por eso que se cancelan ahora
saquemos la calculadora para encontrar
cuáles son estos números tenemos que es
punto 942 x 2.232 entonces lo que
teníamos aquí por 2.262 y esto nos da
2.13 así que este número de aquí va a
ser este número de aquí va a ser este
lado derecho va a ser 2.13 y este número
lado izquierdo es el negativo de ese
menos 2.13 aún tenemos las desigualdades
así es que esto va a ser menor que 17.17
menos la media
que alá
es menor que 2.13 lo que voy a hacer
ahora es resolver para la media pero no
me gusta este signo menos prefiero
invertir aquí los signos prefiero tener
la media menos 17.17 así es que voy a
multiplicar toda la desigualdad por
menos 1 si hacemos esto multiplicando
toda esta desigualdad por menos 1 este
valor de la izquierda esté menos 2.13 se
transforma en 2.13 luego este signo de
menor que al multiplicarlo por menos uno
invierte su sentido por lo cual se
transforma en mayor que lo aquí tenemos
menos 1000 que se transforma en mi
positiva luego éste 17.17 se transforma
en menos
17.17 y este signo de menor que se
transforma en mayor que 2.13 por menos
uno menos 2.13 ya casi acabamos queremos
resolver para mí entonces lo que podemos
hacer es sumar
17.17 a los tres lados de la desigualdad
entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos 2.13
17.17 mayor que mayor que mí
17.17 17.17 simplemente va a ser mi boca
lo cual a su vez es mayor que aquí
teníamos que esto es mayor que en you
que a la vez es mayor que menos 2.13 más
17.17 o una manera más natural de
escribir esto dado que tenemos varios
signos de mayor que aquí tenemos la
cantidad que es mayor
perdón esta es la cantidad que es menor
y aquí tenemos la cantidad que es mayor
vemos que está invertida podemos
escribir esta desigualdad en el sentido
inverso así que esto lo podemos
reescribir de hecho vamos a calcularlo
de una vez saquemos la calculadora y
tenemos el mayor valor que es 2.13 +
17.17 esto nos da igual resulta que el
mayor valor de nuestro intervalo es
igual a 19.3 19.3 este valor de aquí va
a ser entonces a 19 déjame hacerlo con
el mismo color
19.3 que va a ser mayor
19.3 que va a ser mayor que mi y que a
su vez es mayor que menos 2.3
17.17 lo cual podemos calcular como
17.17 2.13 lo cual es igual a 15.04 esto
es igual
15.04 y recuerda todo esto que hemos
hecho lo empezamos considerando con que
había un 95 por ciento de probabilidad
de que un valor aleatorio el estadístico
te cayera dentro de este intervalo
teníamos un estadístico de aleatorio
hicimos talacha matemática hacia el 95
por ciento de probabilidad de que estos
pasos sean verdaderos 95 por ciento de
probabilidad de que esto sea verdadero
hay un 95 por ciento de probabilidad de
que la verdadera media poblacional la
cual coincide con la media de la
distribución muestral de medias hay un
95 por ciento de la probabilidad o más
bien tenemos la confianza que hay un 95
por ciento de probabilidad de que va a
caer dentro de este intervalo hemos
acabado